bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
pour faire un point sur cette économie
russe qui subit donc depuis six mois des
sanctions internationales d'inédites
c'est une des armes de ce conflit
d'abord une question simple à ce que ces
sanctions des répercussions celle
espérée par les occidentaux sur la
russie est ce qu'elles affectent
l'économie russe la réponse est
indubitablement oui mais pas au niveau
qui était sans doute escompté par les
responsables qui ont décidé ces
sanctions la première conséquence de ces
sanctions ça a été nous l'avons vu des
25 février 26 février la déstabilisation
du système financier russe il y avait
deux niveaux de déstabilisation un
niveau direct qui était la chute du
rouble et la chute des marchés
financiers et la fuite des capitaux en
fait les capitaux russes ont quitté la
russie immédiatement après le
déclenchement de la guerre et et le
début des sanctions un rythme qui était
inégalé depuis le début de la transition
économique de la russie depuis vingt ou
trente ans et puis il y avait un
deuxième deuxième question qui se pose
est c est ce que ces sanctions vont
toucher le coeur du système c'est-à-dire
le système énergétique alors le premier
des deux systèmes le système financier a
été
tout à fait
remarquablement maintenu par la banque
centrale qui a mis en place toute une
série de dispositifs pour limiter cette
déstabilisation et ces dispositifs ont
fonctionné ils ont fonctionné parce
qu'ils ont empêché les russes de
continuer à exporter leurs capitaux et
ils ont maintenu des réserves en devises
suffisantes pour faire face à la hausse
13 qui touchait les banques
donc ça c'est une première réponse un
peu inattendu de la part des occidentaux
qui pensaient que le système financier
allait être très fortement perturbée
lorsqu'il reste de ce moment là c'est
l'inflation il ya malgré tout des
conséquences à moyen terme qui sont le
fait que l'inflation a dépassé très
largement les 15% en rythme annuel on
estime que elle se situera un petit peu
au dessus de ce niveau pour l'ensemble
de l'année 2022 ce qui est un problème
pour la russie parce que une grande
partie des ménages russes qui sont à la
limite du seuil de pauvreté sont très
fortement touchés par la hausse des prix
de première nécessité qui est alimenté
par cette inflation donc là on a un
premier problème
c'est un problème de comment l'état peut
faire face à la paupérisation d'une
partie de son de sa population en les
subventionnant donc ça c'est la première
question qui est posée là l'un des
moyens que l'état a de faire face à cela
c'est de puiser dans ses réserves ou de
d'utiliser ces ses ressources fiscales
hélas ce que l'on voit c'est que ces
recettes fiscales sont restés élevés
pourquoi parce que le deuxième système
terre le système énergétique n'a pas été
touchée aussi profondément qu'il que ça
pouvait que l'on pouvait l'imaginer au
départ en particulier parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu un consensus pour stopper les
importations notamment de gaz il est
tout de même je pars d'un nouveau
interrompu tout de même une certaine
hypocrisie finalement dans cette
question l'énergie russe les européens
ont besoin du gaz russe et les russes
ont besoin de le vendre ce gaz
alors je n'appellerais pas ça de
l'hypocrisie je dirais que c'est la
realpolitik
c'est de la réelle politique c'est à
dire que vous ne pouvez pas du jour au
lendemain décider de la destruction de
votre propre économie ni vladimir
poutine ni olaf scholz ni emmanuel
macron devons faire ça donc l'idée c'est
d'essayer d'infliger des dommages à la
partie adverse de l'empêcher de financer
sa guerre tout en évitant que les
dommages collatéraux que l'on va subir
nous mêmes soit insupportable
insupportable pour la population
européenne en particulier on voit quand
même que la hausse des prix de l'énergie
a un impact sur la population européenne
donc ça ça ça une certaine objectivité
mais ça a des conséquences objectives
qui sont en particulier que la rente
pétrolière la rente pétrolière
continue d'affluer en russie qui
continue donc de prélever c'est 30 sur
le reste du monde
simplement parce que même si ses
exportations de pétrole et ses
exportations de gaz ont chuté ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui n'est pas
suffisamment sûr de par la population
c'est que en fait là
l'exportation par exemple de gaz russe à
chuter de 35% vers l'europe et la
turquie 1 c'est énorme c'est inédit
c'est historique mais comme dans le même
temps les prix du gaz ont augmenté très
fortement et bien pour l'état qui reçoit
ses recettes
fiscale en grande partie de la part des
entreprises qui exportent le gaz et qui
reçoit directement par l'intermédiaire
des banques centrales et recettes en
devises et bien c'est un peu un dos lors
d'une certaine manière c'est à dire que
les recettes fiscales continuent
d'affluer et ça ça maintient également
le rouble à un niveau élevé alors il est
maintenu deux par deux phénomènes le
premier c'est suite je vous ai dit c'est
à dire les mesures delà de la banque
centrale visant à contrôler les fuites
de capitaux et le deuxième c'est le haut
niveau des prix de l'énergie qui
maintient ses recettes d'exportation à
un niveau élevé et donc qui maintient un
excédent commercial de la russie
vis-à-vis du reste du monde qui soutient
le rouge voilà c'est donc ces deux
éléments qui fonctionne alors juste un
dernier point c'est sur l'activité
économique la manière dont la croissance
économique russe est affecté on
attendait pour 2022 en janvier 2022 on
attendait une croissance de trois et
demi pour cent aujourd'hui les
prévisions ne sont pas aussi
catastrophiques qu'elles ont pu l'être
en mars avril mai elles sont plutôt de
l'ordre de - 5 - 6 on verra il peut
encore se passer pas mal de choses dans
le deuxième semestre mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire quand même que
la l'économie russe a chuté de près de
10% par rapport aux visions et ça c'est
très extrêmement important et c'est à m
en proportion avec la manière la manière
dont cette guerre a affecté l'économie
européenne l'économie européenne à une
chute de son de ses prévisions panne
dessus de son produit intérieur brut un
mais une chute de ses prévisions
d'environ 1% selon le fmi donc on a un
rapport de 1 à 10 sur les dommages de
cette guerre qui ont touché à la fois
l'économie européenne et l'économie
russe qui est donc pour l'instant dix
fois plus touchés que l'économie
européenne